how bad will it get under Donald Trump
for the next four years we will have to
deal with a narcissistic megalomaniacal
con artist bigot with no political
experience and a wife who was working in
the United States illegally even though
he wants to kick out all the criminal
illegal aliens as he says we knew that
right and we we sort of know that uh we
now need to focus on what is likely to
happen and what is probable to happen
when you have the House and Senate when
you have probably three or four Supreme
Court picks a lot can happen abortion
rights are going to be whittled away the
economy historically not that good under
Republicans much better under Democrats
we will see what happens there
we can expect regresses regressive tax
cuts the rich will get richer as a share
of total wealth we may see a repeal of
the Affordable Care Act it might be
replaced with something it might be
replaced with something worse it might
be replaced with nothing and the u.s. is
going to be an embarrassment around the
world will see declining relations with
other countries other countries will be
less willing to involve the United
States it will hurt our standing in a
really significant way and the right
wingers to the Supreme Court are really
the biggest concern to me
Trump has already said he's going to
pick from a list provided to him by the
Heritage Foundation and we are talking
about six three maybe even a seven two
conservative Supreme Court that will
decide in favor of corporations more
often that it will decide in favor of
individuals and this is a major concern
because you can work more easily Rachel
to compartmentalize Donald Trump's
ability to make long-lasting change
within a four year period but the
Supreme Court is the area where you're
talking about multi-generational impact
from a guy who doesn't know the first
thing about anything related to being
president and and for me the biggest
concern is the Supreme Court yeah I've
kind of always felt that the if there's
an overwhelmingly large amount of one
party in the Supreme Court kind of
undermines the whole purpose in my own
opinion I really think it would
definitely fare better if there's
something in place that could have it a
little bit more evenly split but that
seems to not be feasible now uh the
discussion of Trump being in over his
head is coming up a lot now I mean how
can Donald Trump Pat have a conversation
with Japanese Prime Minister Shinzo Abe
for example what on earth could Trump
talked to him about right or German
Chancellor Angela Merkel it's just silly
I'm II did that this is it's not even an
issue of policy it's an issue of what on
earth is Trump going to be doing there
now the day-to-day life for a lot of
people is is not going to be different
and this week we serve joked yesterday I
still got my dentist's appointment next
week and it's Veterans Day on Friday and
the Sun came up today as President Obama
said uh but the the truth is that this
will disproportionately affect some
people more than others right and
particularly even when we think about
what would happen if the u.s. went in
the direction of Steiff stifling free
speech and really went full
authoritarian I mean it I'm glad that
anytime I want I can go back and live in
Argentina any time if I wanted to get
Israeli citizenship I could do that uh I
could potentially get polish citizenship
but there's a lot of people who don't
have that mobility and they are going to
be disproportionately poorly effected
especially since we're in Massachusetts
if Obamacare goes away we had something
else already that supersedes it and goes
above and beyond Obamacare so people
here we have nearly complete health
coverage in Massachusetts in a lot of
ways there is there's a way to be
insulated from this but not everybody
has that and that's really scary
yeah how do you prevent a dictatorship I
suppose I'm just this kind of
reminiscent of Turkey and I'm thinking
of the Prime Minister when the riots
were going on and people were turning on
the television to cooking shows and
right and then they they had absolutely
no idea what was going on with the riots
so I'm just worried that that might
happen we need independent media I
thought sadly that a Trump win would be
better for shows like ours than a
Hillary win and that's probably true I
didn't vote for Donald Trump but I've
spoken to a number of hosts who say you
know if Hillary wins will our shows will
continue if Trump wins the show's will
do really well overnight
many many new David Pakman show members
signing up just a lot of activity and I
hate that this is where we are but if
there is a silver lining it's that the
audience on our live stream last night
seem to understand this is serious now
this is really serious now and corporate
media is not going to help out forget
about it it's not going to help out so
upping your cable plan to get a couple
more movie channels and keep continuing
to contribute to corporate media it's
not going to change what we saw because
it was independent media talking about
Bernie Sanders it was independent media
pointing out some of the obvious
inconsistencies and just flaws in what
Donald Trump was saying so please if you
if you value what we're doing and
understand we need to support it going
into the midterms in 2020 and 2020 to
sign up for membership david pakman.com
slash membership Warby Parker is
offering a free five day home Tryon to
give you the opportunity to check out
their glasses I personally wear Warby
Parker glasses when I'm not wearing my
contact lenses and I also started with
one of these free at home try ons of
five pairs of glasses you can get your
free home try on and support the david
pakman show at Warby Parker trialed
dot-com slash TDPS
I don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses well the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I liked the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com slash TDP s it costs nothing